alors j'ai une question à vous poser est
ce que dans la salle il ya des parents
lever la main bien haut pour je vois un
super il va de soi pour tout le monde
que d'être parent c'est épanouissant que
c'est le plus beau métier du monde et
que nos enfants nous apporte beaucoup de
bonheur quand j'ai tenu pour la première
fois mes enfants dans l'est dans les
bras la première chose que j'ai fait
j'ai été sentir l'odeur dans leurs coûts
alors je ne sais pas vous mais moi je
trouve que c'est une odeur particulière
ça sent le bébé tout neuf ou alors quand
nos enfants grandissent et commence à
nous répondre avec un sourire et que
leurs petites joues sera se gonfle moi
j'avais passé mon temps à leur faire des
bisous je partirai un appel au crime
c'est du bisou partout et puis quand nos
enfants quand quand arrive quand ils
grandissent un petit peu il nous amène à
faire des choses inimaginables bons
clous et ça y est ça fait vivre
ouais montre fait pipi oui on peut dire
bravo ouais ouais qui n'a pas fait ça
sérieux maintenant levé la main bien ou
que je vous vois ce qu'ils ont eu envie
un jour de jeter ce même enfant par la
fenêtre parce que vous ne pouviez plus
pas plus
le jour j entré maternité avec mon
deuxième enfant
mon grand alors âgé de 2 ans s'est levé
22 fois vous avez bien entendu 22 fois
de son lit d'emblée il nous a donné et
ont franchement j'étais loin mais
vraiment loin d'imaginer ce que j'allais
vivre durant ces quelques mois une lente
mais certaine descente aux enfers un
soir après avoir tenté mille fois de
mettre mon grand lit après une journée
somme toute banale mais tellement
difficile mais deux enfants dorment
enfin il est plus de 22 heures
je ferme la porte de leur chambre et là
je m'écroule littéralement mes jambes ne
tiennent plus je glisse le long d'un
porte et je craque je pleure à n'en plus
finir
il ya tellement d'émotion c'est un vrai
lâcher prise et un tsunami qui me
traversent un lâcher prise
je n'en peux plus de cette vie là et je
n'en veux plus surtout
le burn out maternel ou l'épuisement
maternel est une perte profonde du sens
de la parentalité
il se met en place au bout de trois
étapes la première étape c'est
l'épuisement émotionnel
le matin je posais les pieds au sol et
je savais déjà que ma journée n'était
qu'une suite logique de ma nuit monde ma
fatigue s'est transformé en un
épuisement physique mais aussi morale je
ne pensais qu'à une chose dormir mais
j'en ai commencé en engrangeant et se
terminer de la même façon et j'avais le
sentiment de n'avoir rien terminée c'est
puissant
ce goût d'inachevé ça vous reste en
travers de la gorge la deuxième étape
c'est la distanciation après
l'épuisement capitale patience écoute et
tolérance je n'étais plus capable
d'entendre l'un leurs cris leurs pleurs
les jouets qui tomba ça me mettait dans
une colère tel qu'il fallait que je les
touffes et comment on allait manger des
gâteaux dans la gare ça vous dit quelque
chose
mes enfants c'est ce que j'aime le plus
profondément
mais c'était aussi ma principale source
de stress en réalité c'est pas eux le
problème c'était moi qui n'en pouvait
plus après des mois de lutte j'en suis
venu à faire les choses de manière
automatique la troisième étape c'est le
renoncement le reniement des actions
passés présents et futurs
ainsi qu'une baisse de la productivité
je crois pour ma part c'était le coup de
grâce
j'en suis venu à avoir une image une
image de moi mais désastreuse j'avais le
sentiment de n'être bonne à rien d'être
surtout une mauvaise mère cette petite
voix vous savez qui vous qui vous tirent
vers le bas qui vous amène à vous
critiquer constamment et ben et efficace
croyez-moi on tire mais pas d'un burn
out maternel comme ça de ma propre
expérience par contre j'ai tiré trois
enseignements
le premier mesdames respectez-vous et
devenez égoïste parce que devenir
égoïste c'est se donner la possibilité
de reprendre confiance en soi c'est
s'offrir du temps rien que pour soi et
en y mettant le mot plaisir
waouh se faire plaisir quels mots exquis
dans mes oreilles et bien trop souvent
oubliée au détriment du mot de voir ces
savoirs aussi dire non parce que non
c'est dire parce que non c'est aussi
dire non
savez vous que vous l'aimez vous n'êtes
pas corvéable à souhait ce qui est
intéressant que non c'est qu'on peut le
dire à la mer est aussi aux copines
envahissante
je me suis autorisé à sortir de ma cage
dorée
je me suis autorisé à penser à moi et ça
a été un tel bonheur une telle bouffée
d'oxygène que j'en ai culpabiliser vous
avez bien entendu
j'ai culpabilisé de sortir et de penser
à moi
l'être humain est parfois compliqué par
contre je me suis prise de passion pour
la couture
j'ai dévoré les blocs de couturière j'ai
été dans les magasins de tissus à
toucher la matière et avoir toutes ses
couleurs
parce que j'ai pris plaisir à sortir
j'ai arrêté de culpabiliser et vous
savez même j'ai fait pire
j'ai osé faire la sieste alors que dans
le dans le lave-vaisselle n'étaient pas
faites dans le bac et que mon vous savez
le bac à repasser en général il fait ça
eh bien il me narguer en déportant de
partout
le deuxième enseignement que j'ai pu
tirer
c'est reprenez la main sur votre
quotidien
comment fait place nette tout simplement
commencer à voir à faire l'inventaire de
votre quotidien à voir où sont vos
problèmes et surtout à trouver vos
solutions
pas celle de la voisine pas de celle de
2,2 je sais pas qui de vos copines de
votre nom vos solutions désencombrer
votre maison j'irai même plus loin
désencombrer votre vie quand
j'accompagne des mères la première chose
que je fais c'est que je demande à ce qu
elle réalise un état des lieux de leur
temps sur une durée de 7 à 15 jours
alors c'est vrai c'est un travail
fastidieux
parce qu on doit noter ce qu'on fait
mais à cela il ya deux objectifs le
premier que la mère se rende compte de
la quantité astronomique qu'elle fait
dans son quotidien
canaille paoli en disant j'ai rien fait
de concret dans ma journée
le deuxième objectif c'est que avec
cette base qui est l'inventaire elle va
pouvoir se créer une routine et du matin
et une routine du soir ça c'est le début
d'une organisation plus sereine le
troisième enseignement est le plus
important à mes yeux c'est redonner du
sens à votre parentalité comprenez ce
qui vous a amené à faire un burn out
maternel c'est pas un hasard si ça c'est
fait mettez des mots sur vos maux m11x
prenez du recul moi je me suis posé
énormément de questions plaint tout le
temps je me suis posé des questions sur
la ma façon de faire ma façon d'être
ce que j'ai reçu comme éducation ce que
la société nous impose au quotidien je
me suis aussi posé la question de ce que
je voulais transmettre à mes enfants
les valeurs que je voulais leur donner
--ou une chose est sûre aujourd'hui
c'est que la communication est
primordiale pour moi il est possible de
s'en sortir je les fais je me suis
reconstruite
j'ai même été plus loin dans mes
démarches parce qu'aujourd'hui je suis
accompagnantes en parentalité
oui j'accompagne des femmes pour
qu'elles retrouvent leur véritable place
de mer etc ainsi à puisse élever leurs
enfants avec coeur et bienveillance ce
que j'ai appris sur moi et précieux mais
le plus important c'est que à travers ça
j'ai recréé un véritable lien d'amour
avec mes enfants parce que je les avais
perdu comme je m'étais perdu
vous imaginez vous imaginez bien qu
après vous avoir inventé ma souffrance
de mer mon mari et moi on n'a pas été
assez fou pour faire un troisième enfant
c'est mal me connaître
après avoir dit jamais au grand jamais
je n'aurais un autre enfant eh bien nous
nous sommes donné la possibilité d'avoir
une troisième une petite fille cinq ans
après notre deuxième enfant
en réalité je me suis donné la
possibilité de vivre une parentalité
complètement différente épanouissante et
aligné pour moi qui ait du sens j'ai
fait tatouer un mot à l'intérieur de mon
poignet si vous le voyez on le voit
c'est le mot toujours pour moi il
signifie toujours y croire toujours
avancer et ne jamais jamais renoncer